If we stay under water for a long time without an
oxygen mask, what will happen, we will
start suffocating, but if we talk about such aquatic
animals which remain in water for 24 hours,
then which are your fishes?
How do fishes survive in water?
Basically, if we talk about fishes, then
gills are present here, through which what it
does is that the water current will
come inside your fish and it will provide oxygen to the fish,
whereas in these fishes, only
our gills will be present, but if  If we talk about
Boli fishes, the
gills present here are covered with your oklam and
what will the gills do in both the fishes, it will provide oxygen to the fishes.